and so I'm gonna have a few propositions
for the evening the first one is that
art thinking allows us to expand our
notions of space and time and our
thinking is a methodology by which
artists develop their work and it's a
methodology I've researched and
developed and and so just to state the
case that this is my methodology I think
it applies to a lot of other artists I'm
going to propose that it's a valid
methodology for creating artwork and one
the artist views but first of all I want
to talk about design thinking which is
where this came out of so design
thinking is I entered the popular
lexicon it's this five-step process that
was really pioneered and by the d.school
here at Stanford and and the first step
is this empathize step and that's one
where you're learning about the audience
for which you're developing the design
work so it kind of makes sense it's a
user centred approach and the second
step is defining the problem and so what
you're doing is figuring out what your
users might want and then sort of
bounding the scope of the problem in the
first two steps and that's the the first
two steps of the design thinking process
now the art thinking methodology has a
different sort of five step process that
developed I do want to acknowledge some
of the various thinkers I had been
reading and researching over the years
to get to this point and this is Amy
Whitaker she's written about her version
of art thinking and but she's written
about some really interesting ideas
about having studio time and about
failure modes I think had been really
influential for me also John Maeda who
is a luminary and and designer and
thinker who has amazing ideas and one of
my favorite is this quote which he says
when people say I don't get art that
means artists working but it art art is
supposed to be confusing they're
supposed to go into a gallery or museum
and kind of wonder like what is you're
seeing is supposed to ask you questions
and make you wonder why you're there
make you feel uneasy not provide easy
answers and this isn't to say that the
writing about art isn't problematic
because they're writing about art is
often terrible like we've all walked
into museum spaces not interested what
the text is about but to go into an art
space and see something that is is
confusing is the norm and so this is the
five step are thinking diagram
that I've been working on and so it goes
through the first step here is an
inquiry step and this starts with some
sort of observation some sort of
question maybe an experiment with the
material just some sort of point of
curiosity right and and and so this is a
for me I have an idea book and all my
all my ideas go into that idea book
anything that's kind of a valid inquiry
will go in there so some really bad
stuff and really good stuff and really
mediocre stuff I'd like to say my art
idea book with something like this but
it's actually just an Evernote document
so I'm gonna share with you three three
of my bad art ideas and you're welcome
to borrow any of them that's a bad idea
number one is to bury 3d printed fake
fossils for future generations so
unicorn skulls fake animals I'm not
gonna do this anyone else wants to do it
you can you don't have to credit me bad
idea number two RGB war it's a iPhone
Android app so you choose it game red
green or blue and repeatedly press that
color and get people to tap and take
over territory so not only is it a bad
idea it's like a socially useless idea
just a waste of time bad idea number
three is EU gasm so you wear an EEG
headset and report people's orgasms and
you sort of create like a sort of
pleasure signature for each person and
some sort of data visualization I
thought this would be well we'll just
let it go at that
and so the next the next stage after
this inquiry stage is kind of boosting
some of these ideas out the idea book
into the experimentation stage and this
is the most fun part of any project and
or any sort of art work it doesn't
really exist as a project at this point
you're just kind of kind of
around and just throwing stuff at the
wall seeing what happens for tweets in
space this meant building these janky
little receivers and then Arduino and
sending the messages back and forth and
kind of thinking about protocols and
messaging systems and just using our
imaginations and having fun with the
project the next the third phase is the
shaping phase and this is where you're
sort of bringing all the different
pieces and parts into a cohesive kind of
whole and this is where the project
really
like like a form that you can work with
for tweets in space this was where we
realized that we needed a messaging
system but also some sort of media
strategy at the same time that really
was two arms of the same project up to
that point we hadn't thought about the
media that I mentioned we thought oh my
gosh was a tactical media project of
course like we need publicity to make
this out this project work and the
fourth stage is refinement and to
distinguish that from shaping it it's
like imagining have this like sort of
blob of an artistic project that's a
cohesive whole refining it you're
smoothing at the edges and you're
conceptually tightening up and if you
don't go through this refinement stage
you end up with this artwork that
doesn't quite work in a gallery space
first so for tweets in space what that
meant is that we were going through and
thinking about how to write the text
developing the press list like coming up
with talking to physicists and figuring
out the exact parameters of the
messaging system and really kind of
making it to a cohesive whole and the
last phase is a showing the artwork
phase and this is an important phase
because if you don't show the artwork
you never come into a space where you
get critical feedback and it's that
critical feedback that really completes
the work making yourself feel vulnerable
actually thinking about the display
elements and this is the final part
where you're thinking about how it's
going to be presented and and with that
showing phase lets you do is it also let
you come back to your point of inquiry
right so after you show it you get more
questions and you can come back and
develop the work further and make more
work and so this art thinking model
nowhere in there are we really thinking
about except for slightly at the very
end but we're not really thinking about
these bounded approaches that you just
have in design thinking they're
open-ended approaches you start with
inquiry and experiment and then you sort
of shape this form that starts with this
open-ended approach an unbounded
approach and this is how our just
approach their artwork in my experience
[Music]